you obviously grew up in an age where
you got legal weed well I I well I mean
look I had a sketchy ass drug dealer
when I was in high school this High
School
I smoked weeds I've been smoking weed
since I was 14.
High School you had a drug dealer
how else was I gonna get wheat a girl
that I had a small thing with in high
school he was her best friend they were
Rave buddies but also I met him and she
was like oh he can get you weed and I
was like Nikki great we're gonna be
great friends
um he was semi-sketchy remember all
those times I told you before I went out
to a party to a friend's house I was
going to 7-Eleven yeah yeah he lived
down the street from us yeah so I just
walked to him let me just tell you first
of all I love how you dropped these
tidbits of [__] I didn't know you want
to hear another tidbit of [__] yeah I
used to deal with what out of my
Hollywood apartment when I moved out
the the one on Hollywood Boulevard
right after I moved out of Curson during
the during the pandemic I needed some
extra bread so I started selling some
selling some weed on the side where
would you get that weight from my drug
dealer
from that dude name not mentioned
yeah yeah yeah the one that I yeah yeah
and so I was I would I would I would
take also but it wasn't like it wasn't
like I was the source I would take
orders I would get what they want I
would
I would charge them a little bit extra
so that I was at least making some a bit
of a profit but I mainly sold to friends
and were you selling basically
to pay for your weed
no I was just can I be honest I was just
selling just so I had a little extra
money in my pocket but yeah you're right
once I sold a certain amount I could pay
for my next pickup how much you think
how long are you doing it and how much
were you making six months and
like I said most people I sold to were
friends so I was only making why weren't
they just going to the weed store
because uh the prices that I had were so
much better
and there's no tax right right right how
much do you think you were making a
month
I'll leave uh
trying to think is it dependent there
was my the Buddies who I was selling to
if they went through it slower you know
what I'm saying like like profit was
slower so it just kind of depended but I
don't know I would probably do it
four or five times a month
probably just make like a quick extra
150 bucks total yeah
like I said it was it was nothing crazy
like I wasn't like pushing pounds yeah
dude because when you said you were sold
weed I was like that yeah that's not it
I was a middle man yeah but then there
were some times where I would buy extra
from my guy and then if I had like I
have I have a buddy if his friends
needed something I would overcharge the
[__] out of them but also I but also I
have a scale with a solo cup and like I
you know I at a certain point in time at
a certain one time if you came over to
my apartment there was there was a
drawer with different weights and
different bags do you remember scale on
the inside can I tell you you know over
the last couple months I've been telling
you tell me some things that I don't
know I just thought about that like
right now this fits in that [__]
category yeah I used to sell weed fits
in that category yeah it's perfect
bring it
I like to smoke weeds
[Music]
[Applause]